another report released today shed new
light on our online data habits in
particular storing photos it's claimed
that unwanted digital photos produce the
same amount of carbon emissions as more
than a hundred thousand return flights
from london to australia so do we all
need to take more responsibility for
tackling the climate crisis
vicky
we think about what we do at home don't
we we think about the way in which we
use energy we think about the cars that
we drive we think about the things that
we eat for example i've never even
considered
my phone and the photographs that i take
as being a factor here
well absolutely and i have to say when i
read the report i immediately looked at
all my photographs well i didn't look at
them all because of course there are so
many uh i like everyone else is keeping
rather a lot of data on our phones and
computers that perhaps we don't need to
do um but the knowledge that um
platforms like
whether it's facebook google
um for example
are in fact making us all and they
themselves consume an awful lot of
energy it's been around for some time
and
the figures are such that suggest that
in fact the energy consumed through all
our uses if you like is something
equivalent to
airline emissions
global airline emissions at present
which is pretty large that's about three
to four percent
of global emissions and of course there
is a huge increase in the use and
although we've read about this of course
we individually didn't think that just
googling something uh a few times also
of course you know emits at the end of
the day a lot of co2 um what
i'll worry about is that this report
says what we as individuals should do
but obviously policymakers should know
that this is happening the data has been
out there for some time and we know that
it's going to be even bigger in the
future i mean the question now with post
covid and us all using a lot of social
media and other ways in terms of
communicating that is supposed to be
good for the environment i think
something needs to give um so we can't
just be living in this ignorance or at
least most people not realizing that
what they're doing is also contributing
to worsening the environment and
i don't know and i haven't quite thought
about what the implications of this can
be whether indeed you know all those
platforms can be more energy efficient
but obviously they need to okay and
simon i did the same as vicky i looked
immediately when i read this at the
number of photos on my phone i don't
even want to admit it
um
vicky talked about the responsibility of
individuals is there something we can
all do to clean up our habits and what
about the companies themselves
well i looked at this report as a
conscientious scientist and looked at
the calculations behind it and what
they're saying is that all of this
social media and internet activity is
about 0.2
of our emissions over the whole year so
it's very very small and we need to keep
in mind the big picture here if we get
our electricity system down to zero
emissions through renewables then we can
then take as many photographs as we like
you